Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Todos amamos los fuegos artificiales...
las luces, los colores,
y, claro, esa gran explosión.
Pero la historia de
los fuegos artificiales
no es todo abrazos y festejos.
Mucho antes de esos
fuegos artificiales épicos,
unos químicos chinos inventaron
el ingrediente clave
que impulsa esas luces
brillantes hacia el cielo.
Esa invención fue lo que
ahora llamamos pólvora.
Nuestra historia se remonta
a la antigua China
a mediados del siglo IX
cuando los primeros alquimistas chinos
trataban de crear una poción
de la inmortalidad.
En cambio, crearon un polvo inflamable
que quemó muchas de sus casas.
Rápidamente advirtieron
que este polvo negro,
al que llamaron medicina de fuego,
era precisamente lo contrario a algo
que te hiciera vivir para siempre.
En esos primeros días,
los chinos aún no habían descubierto
cómo hacer explotar al polvo;
simplemente era muy inflamable,
y sus ejércitos lo usaron
para hacer flechas incendiarias
e incluso un lanzallamas.
Pero una vez que descubrieron
las proporciones adecuadas
de ingredientes para crear una explosión,
empezaron a usar el polvo aún más,
creando fuegos artificiales para mantener
alejados a los espíritus malignos
y bombas para defenderse
de los invasores mongoles.
Y fueron estos mongoles,
muy probablemente,
quienes difundieron
la invención de la pólvora
por el mundo.
Después de interceptar los ataques chinos,
aprendieron a producir
pólvora por sí mismos
y la llevaron consigo
en sus conquistas en Persia e India.
Guillermo de Rubruck,
un embajador europeo ante los mongoles,
fue probablemente el responsable
de llevar la pólvora
a Europa en torno al año 1254.
A partir de allí, ingenieros
e inventores militares
crearon todo tipo de armas de destrucción.
Desde bombas, hasta armas y cañones,
la pólvora dejó su marca en el mundo
de maneras en cierta forma terribles,
en contraste con las marcas hermosas
que puede dejar en el aire.
Entonces, ¿cómo impulsa el polvo negro
los fuegos aritficiales al cielo?
Puede que hayas visto antiguas
películas del Oeste o dibujos animados
en las que se enciende
un reguero de pólvora
que conduce a un barril grande
y obviamente explosivo.
Cuando el fuego llega al barril,
ocurre una gran explosión.
Pero, ¿por qué no explota
el propio reguero?
La razón es que la combustión del polvo
libera energía y gases.
Mientras arde el reguero,
estos se liberan al aire circundante.
Pero cuando la pólvora
está contenida en el barril,
la energía y los gases
no pueden escapar fácilmente
y se acumula hasta que
¡BUUM!
El contenedor de fuegos
artificiales proporciona
una salida única hacia arriba
para canalizar esta energía explosiva.
La mecha enciende la pólvora
y la energía toma
la salida más fácil del contenedor,
lanzando al fuego artificial
alto en el cielo.
Luego la llama se abre camino
por el interior del contenedor
y se produce la misma reacción
muy por encima de nuestras cabezas.
Así, si bien los alquimistas chinos
nunca encontraron el
compuesto de la vida eterna,
hallaron algo
que daría forma a toda la civilización;
algo que ha provocado
muchos momentos trágicos
en la historia humana,
y aún así nos da esperanza
cuando al festejar miramos hacia arriba
en el cielo la noche colorida.